hello we are here on the sticks out
podcast number seven with Kate regal van
West did I say that right yeah okay and
why don't you tell us a little bit about
yourself and who you are oh man on a big
question
[Applause]
I'm person you found the circuit so the
young age totally loved it sounds pretty
athletic chick I didn't like competing
young age did circus and music and art
and all sorts of stuff which is how I
came to poised in circus in the US and
yeah then they just realized boy is
awesome it feels really good I don't I
didn't know why it felt so good or what
it was doing but I just love the way
that felt but some point it occurred to
me that maybe there was some really like
good health benefits for employees you
know obvious from what I felt and people
that I had taught so I then went on a
journey to scientifically prove at least
try to start that process so that
brought me to New Zealand I basically
just skipped over my whole life like I
was in this born in this town called
normal and then I lived in Chicago and I
live in Boston I like ran archaeology
program at Harvard and all this other
stuff and then I made it to New Zealand
because I figure you ought to hear about
the Poincare so why don't you wait are
you an American
are you an American okay so you first
picked up poi say in Boston is that the
first place you saw it who was the first
person that introduced you to this
artform or where did you sort of see it
first or yeah in my hometown in Normal
Illinois there's this guy named Zach
Stevens a really good friend of mine he
was Jean boy in the circus not as an act
actually he was just try to see we were
in a circus together and he was just
practicing coy at circus practice like
on the side and I saw him doing it I
didn't actually try it for awhile
because I was busy like too
cappy's and other cool stuff but I've
actually had to try it um I really liked
it and then ya became like obsessed with
it actually so he taught me everything
that he knew he was basically my only
teacher for a long time like 15 years
ago so it wasn't so much YouTube culture
so I was really learning everything it
was great so so let's let's go through
your journey a little bit so before we
get to your current state so we're in
Boston did you have the idea to maybe
continue research in poi while you're in
Boston and also was there some kind of
an event like that catalyzed your love
of it or um yes we had a little
performance troupe me and two of Zach's
neighbors so we would do like fire from
like haunted houses ah that's why it's
so loud in here how can identify on who
look and it just turned off it was like
such peace so yeah we were doing that
stuff in my hometown and then I moved to
Chicago to do a master's degree um so
like straight when I moved to Chicago
it's like I want to keep doing this
point thing so I remember I bought this
like I went to like this weird shot that
was closing down and I bought a rack or
I can hang Boyan that folded up so I
could fit it in my bicycle and I bought
a bunch of socks from like Julian socks
coms and and I set up this rack with
this sign that was like fully for sale
and I was gonna advise kids like teach
and it was a total disaster like nobody
stopped it was so tiring like I never
busted on my own before doing koi so I
was giving like everything I had every
second it was completely exhausting so
that was like my the moment I landed
but I kept falling that songs mainly
thinking I might perform with play so I
was doing some fire stuff and then
people asked where they can learn so
then I started teaching and that's when
I started to realize just how powerful
it was because every when I was teaching
was telling me stories about boy and how
good it felt you know so what was like a
story you heard in the States prior to
your departure from the states that like
got you like like what kind of benefits
were you hearing about boy like what I
mean I don't I don't know a ton about
what you do so it's kind of nice like
what what what type of health benefits
did you find the most intriguing to
pursue floor space so that's why I
really started teaching and hearing a
lot because before that I was just like
I quit my roommates it's like a little
bit cramped yes so then I was going to
because people are coming to me for
lessons but because going on in there
like running this Center on the side and
I like now you can use any real time
like back in the day
so I did like a school project and it
was pretty people were intrigued so I
was like huh you think boy in academia
like interesting so I started off with
as a musical instrument so I made the
orbit are so I like embedded
accelerometers and gyroscopes in quarter
about like it didn't know much and you
like where it wasn't its orbit and how
fast it was going and I remember the
orbit are because that's I remember
Newton did some kind of orbit our act in
the flow show New York you probably can
find that video it's pretty long I don't
know too much now just to see that but
thinking back I think I did you take a
workshop I taught in Chicago over that
it's feels like like an upstairs of like
a crusty building yeah yeah that was me
it was me and Jordan and I don't know
it's crazy I feel bad that I can't
remember but I feel like that sound
Elliott prepared it talked about me
let's go back to you so I'm thinking
that so so back to the point thing so I
I'm sorry Cassie it's really cool that a
lot of artists are koi artists coming
from art background this is pretty neat
because it seems as if the work you do
now significantly contrasted so maybe
you could kind of discuss what type of
work do you do now and I we see a lot I
think a lot of people see what you do on
the internet but I think sometimes it's
almost like potentially to scholarly for
them it seems scholarly like in a
nutshell what exactly are you doing
these days and what type of research are
you a part of yes so the reason I
switched over to study
health and poise is because when I was
working on that musical instrument I was
having trouble like finding funding and
getting momentum and stuff and I just
thought man like I see the power of this
and I know other people do too but it's
not the people who have money in the
positions I care about money but I just
like everywhere so I was also trying to
[Music]
do some research and maybe open the door
actually applied for six PhD programs
and I was working on the orbit are to
keep doing choir music and I got
rejected from all of them so I took
three years off I was doing other stuff
and then they came back to life yeah I
was like academia is just a good place
to do research like I don't really care
about academia I don't wanna stay there
I don't want to be teachers or something
back they have other resources and
people with the knowledge so I thought
it would make sense and the credibility
you know you need research to come out
somewhere so what school are you at in
New Zealand University of Auckland
Auckland and so what is what types of
like just to give us like maybe one of
your more successful I don't know if
there's unsuccessful ones what research
projects have you conducted I'm a doctor
and I just did a large-scale clinical
trial with healthy older adults so
people over 60 learning coy or Tai Chi
they did it for one month and before and
after that I tested them on physical
cognitive and emotional well-being it's
a little more complicated so I'm curious
so how did you assess their improvement
in these areas of cognitive function and
physical function like what were the
measures say yeah so I cast my net
pretty ride because it was the first
study so I had quite a lot of tests and
okay so like for physical tests as
things like this grip strength like both
your pinch grip and your like hand grip
the range of motion and your upper limb
like shoulder elbow wrist lower body
strength which was measured like um
these are older people remember selling
um sitting and standing from a chair as
many times as you can in 30 seconds um
pan like dexterity like the nine-hole
peg test where you take a little pegs
and you have to put them in two holes as
fascism and cognitive was the whole
battery of tests they were all on a
computer so it's measuring things like
people's reaction time memory so like it
was do short term memory and long term
so like you only show them a list of
words and then they'd have to then see
all these words that they were supposed
to remember
and then they'd see a longer list of
words and they had to pick out the ones
that they had just seen and then like 30
minutes later they had to do again
questionnaire for people I'm not sure
that's me general yes so basically first
results were due to the point or
something else or what so we have to do
those tests twice one month apart
without doing any play or anything
because then someone improves the second
time then maybe used because we got
better at the quest so we needed a seat
we need to make a stable at baseline so
two rounds of the same exact same test
right at the start um another one I
included just proposed by manual
coordination which is the coordination
between your hands timing and directions
of circle drawing okay yes so so I got a
question for you so what like if you
were to give three takeaways you got
from that study that you know I always
feel funny talking about research
because I understand that like the
takeaways can be twisted to the way that
you want to convey your nothing you're
doing that but that's something that
does happen with results well what are
three takeaways yeah attention attention
so those are the two it's not about
achieving the trick or being able to do
the weave or whatever
somehow the experience of doing coy
having fun having a laugh at challenging
yourself did you teach them in a group
setting or in one-on-one time thinking
of the study now but was with a
one-on-one communication or was it like
just true of all research anytime
someone's getting individual or group
attention attention from the people
administering the study from their peers
whatever there's always that aspect of
research that it's hard to separate out
so what's uh so your how many years are
you at too busy to you're done yeah
what's your doctorate again I work
between the Center for brain research in
the dance department so complicated um
it took me three years so I do that PhD
as quick as you can
I submitted three years to the day
because I wanted to get it out there
like I'm close I didn't have any funding
to carry on did get the funding so just
the study itself cost $20,000 to pay the
staff to think about like as low budget
as it could be like twenty thousand is
probably not a lot for like a large
alright so let's mix up this question
because I'm so D let's go to flow
because I'm just gonna ask so do you are
you like what are you gonna do the bomb
question what is your thoughts on flow
personally like and what is it
to you personally and you see it as a
benefit I start there yeah I I think I
tried to find flow I'm drawn to things
where I can get into that state so like
so I mean like most people thing like
coins like my life's work if I and it's
everything like man I like so many other
things too I just thought like let's
follow this thing because I think I mean
same with music and same drawing and
same with doing acrobatics and same with
everything like for me I'm a process
person like I don't care as much about
the end result so I just love being in
the moment in the zone really fun for me
really excited me so I see so do you
think flow is like being in the moment
is that what you would classify flow for
you as is sort of like is it like a
letting go is it like that like where
does that exist for you yeah I think
it's fine that you're in the moment
enjoying the moment not focus on any
kind of end goal or purpose you're just
sort of in the zone totally focused yeah
do you need prerequisites to reach that
state for you I'm like like you know so
for example just thinking like
everything a lot about it like what gets
you to the like if you believe flow is
this sort of open-ended activity that
where you're drawing together
a body of knowledge of your body and
whatever you're doing like what gets you
there for you like how do you get to
that place yeah also be a good mix of
things like it can't be something too
hard or too easy because then you're
like bored with it or it's too
challenging or whatever size to be like
not gonna join it and then you can't get
there either and it also has to be like
I guess that goes along with the
challenge like it has to be really
engaging to you just like check out so I
mean that shit's throwing me all the
time
is you you know Sunday now what I
couldn't get into that statement
initially because maybe I'm learning so
it's really hard like I will be able to
later but then it becomes boring and
then it firstly it's always [\h__\h] for me
what how smelly guys check it out I just
like do things that I enjoy I did any of
your research students this is like get
into them like I'm just envisioning some
of your people in your research study
getting know they were like one of the
individuals rockin in your yeah I mean
maybe this interesting because maybe it
was just like my teaching foot they
weren't really getting in the flow state
because I think I was constantly
challenging them maybe too much
mmm so they were always working on
learning and I throw it's time to just
enjoy the movement but it wasn't like I
was creating an atmosphere for flow
because I was constantly so it was like
oh let's just like music you know just
like feel what we're doing
more like oh you just got that okay yeah
no yeah that's an interesting thing to
thing I didn't think about that but uh
yeah wanting to see results from your
assessment necessitating maybe you
ensuring that they actually are
practicing these fine motor skills icons
yeah I had the interview with a couple
of times ago that just made me think
about it's like one person was saying
that the flow state doesn't exist for
her because she thinks that being
knowing choreography knowing what's
coming is actually where she experiences
it most like an organized so two ways of
like an actor can find nuances of how
things work if they know their lines
better kind of thing and then another
person backs we was talking about how
the flow state is something where like
he does a thing where he blindfolds his
students at one point and like rocks out
sort of encourage that ability to sort
of like feel open in that time I was
just thinking about how that's like
interesting that there's so many
different perspectives and that flow is
something that especially with props
because you have to have a skill level
of entry it's just kind of yeah I
thought it was I mean this isn't a only
practice twice a week for one month so
we didn't really reach that make up
wherever you want
call me back okay well like that the
interesting part is like I was thinking
like there could be again I've just been
thinking about that some of the other
interviews that were like maybe there is
an educational difference that would
occur with all those things if it were
taught in a way where like the openness
of the success of them I don't know if
it's actually that's where I was that's
where a lot of gripes come with how
certain people teach if they teach via
this way where everything's okay they
don't learn good technique they don't
learn you know how to do it right well
at the same time if you're given that
sort of open sort of playing field you
can be who you are more maybe for some
people yeah I don't always try to teach
can I teach a lot like outside the study
team I always try to you could kind of
tell straight away like I guess this is
awesome I give this workshop to a group
of lawyers the other day and there was
this woman in the back that was just
like doing her thing like I was like
teaching like a pretty structured lesson
and she was in fact like there's music
cling and she's just listening to the
music and just like just like doing
whatever it was like so teach generally
and then kind of go around in yeah so
what I know what's next for you so you
graduated studies done are you working
on it look you have another study you're
ramping up where you gonna maybe change
career don't know like just what's next
yeah I recently had its two new plans
always thinking of doing another study
on people with mild cognitive impairment
which is usually what happens before you
get to mention not always I was gonna do
that I'm in Vancouver there's a
neuroscientist there but we couldn't
find the funding and I didn't get this
big granted I was applying for
so I real quick to scientist switch
gears cuz I've already wrapped up
everything in New Zealand thinking I was
going to do that so I had quit like I
was teaching at the University
all this stuff tonight I was done so
instead of like just starting up my own
business like doing coy house up and see
if I can make that run so it's been a
really it's been just a couple of months
out
what is your business tell us tell me
focusing on aged care and so I'm working
with some facilities in New Zealand
develop programs which basically in the
end we'll be training their staff
because they usually don't have the
money to have someone like me or some
koi expert or whoever coming in all the
time right
so other they need is for their staff to
feel comfortable doing koi themselves
and comfortable teaching employee so
that people who live there and I was
working with all levels of care so like
I did a one-month trial working with
people with dementia people at hospital
people at rest home and also healthy
people so just trying to find out what
works for these different populations
and then trying to find out and then you
know they're expected online resources
plus my training or whatever that can
help them so that they could do koi so
that's like one thread that I'm
currently doing right now that I'm
working on but like I just did all their
notes for my study because it made sense
with like improving the aging population
I thought it'd be really great place to
start
I have no like particular demographics
in a lot of different ways so I'm just
starting with so now we have
so now I can bring it to these this
looks like a whole plan so now I can
bring it to these places yes
evidence-based program and then maybe
that will launch me to be able to do
other stuff like go back to the orbit
are making music employed like that
would be great um bigger projects yeah
actually it kind of I got to interesting
thought so I I work at a school teacher
well I work at a school and I take them
to the Children's Hospital Pennsylvania
which is like a research facility they
just built this massive building and
they have a lot of VR stuff this I'm
just thinking about this VR stuff for
children with autism that helps train
them in varying circumstances and some
of that VR stuff is actually starting to
be tethered to like motion like like
literally they it's like this crazy
thing where if they see their hands
doing the motion maybe they understand
how the motion marks better since it's
not there it's kind of like a wild thing
but I was just thinking like maybe
there's also some of that like boy can
help on that and maybe helping gain
greater sort of like occupational
therapy type stuff or like writing
skills for like I worked in schools
where kids can't write and that like
severely affects motivation and it's
usually boys unfortunately boys and they
can't basically their success in their
handwriting people pooping on their
handwriting basically is like a direct
line downwards with their success and
just thinking about some of the other
areas where you can probably help and
that's friggin awesome I got real good
one this questions really good so you're
in frickin New Zealand right like boy
was made there so like tell me about
some of the connections that maybe
you've had or your studies I've had to
the people of New Zealand and like the
Maori and like how that works out
because I think that is kind of trippy
that maybe it's New Zealand is ye you
could do that study there I don't know
but I'm just like why do people have
more motivation for it but like yeah
what kind of connections in Maori people
have we had and like with your
experience in New Zealand or with your
studies yeah I mean the reason I wanted
to come here was because of that my koi
started here with her Madhuri and so I
wanted to be here
like I could have done this study in the
US so I can you still hear me
yeah yeah okay so tricky stock and also
people in New Zealand don't most people
don't know that poorly exists outside of
Maori ploy and they don't see well we do
they don't see fire poi and flow arts
and any of that stuff they don't see
that as koi
so when you say boy in New Zealand
people are thinking Mari koi I thinking
kapa haka which is Maori performing arts
period so there was a lot of confusion
at the beginning when I said I'm
studying poi poi which always goes with
singing and and stepping in it's part of
modern culture and this is huge thing so
oh no I'm just saying y'all wait on a
chord like spinning that around like
people do all over the world why are you
talking about so I had it real quick
that's been really interesting because
you know you say POI in the u.s. one
thing and you say boy there's no way to
like differentiate like everything we do
is called boy it's like contact Boyer
anyway it's confusing so yeah going off
to like a really interesting start and
I've been here three and a half years
now and the whole time that I've been
here I've just been trying to floors
these connections because it takes time
and there's no replacement for time when
it comes to me they have no reason to
trust you they've been taking advantage
of outsider do you have to gain that
trust and so it's just spend a lot of
time having conversations explaining
what I'm doing just being open to
listening to
totally fascinating and I'm also
learning you're like stepping and
singing like it's you class are you
taking classes at the University which
is amazing I take a university class
when people present I it's so cool well
actually I that was cool but this is
like blows my mind you get there and
everyone's like before class just like
yes but it's mostly people who have had
experience doing Kohanga before like me
in high school
that's exciting
it's fun to be a beginner though so
what's the hardest part about Maori boys
like so I've seen we've all seen the
video like YouTube videos maybe yeah
they make it's a percussive thing it
seems to some extent and people think
it's easy because these videos there's
like huge groups of people from far away
on the stage and they're all moving
together and it's like let me tell you
right now she is not easy like I can
show you you like pop for your teeth is
complex they changed the way the points
lies and the way they changed planes and
the way they coordinate their body and
how fast it's moving is like very hard I
would challenge any points that are out
there to do these like routines for that
morning they'll find it hard
yeah this boy gets a lot of slack like
oh they're not even doing anything it's
not about that anyway more than that
like every action they call it actions
moves the action like has a meaning it
represents part of their culture it's
telling a story and you're singing that
story as you're doing so what is the poi
itself what is it yeah I'm just like an
instrument is the training like
entertainment there's a lot of women
actually sitting down together and then
now it's just persevere and huge
competitions
so like when it's competition time
you'll see the high school students like
on the bus with their boy it's really
cool like I was in the u.s. yeah is it
hard like here is really safe especially
like as a LuAnn like it's super awesome
and cheap all know what
like but I mean you have like a steezy
boy right you know it's not like I mean
I'm maybe I'm like making a brash like a
plastic bag wrapped around a rack three
point three point one handed butterflies
I think I do that like how do they rock
yeah like 13 I'm learning has throws and
catches and software wraps around your
hand and switches plane are you gonna
like be a part of like a whole thing is
there like a recital coming up or
something yeah you can't just like join
how do you spell that
and so like is it I'm gonna as a random
is it like do you have to be Mari to do
it like in the schools or is it like
even the cocky or white students do it
or is it more like I just think about
this is like Irish dance could be
something you'd consider like that but
usually it's Irish kids for the most
part
where the sites that have pervaded all
culture or just for the memory still or
yeah to be honest I don't really know
like tend to not see many outsiders like
when you look at how much things pretty
good so I was just thinking of other
questions but do you have any questions
for me I just figured I would go for
that this is like the new little second
it is any question for me I'm happy to
answer any as well but I have more like
a couple more for about five ten more
minutes but do you have any plans for me
about what I do cuz I figure that well
we're gonna in a board game just send
right uh-huh like cards in there and
Stefan alright I have some art that I'm
working with this artist have that a
Mexican middle school science teacher so
right now I am engaged in that I've run
the floor Earth Institute which is
something I really enjoy and reforming
that every year it's not like it stays
the same ever we have seven events and
then we do the fire safety we have those
for ten free safety lessons online we
we're starting the consent campaign in
the past year which has been quite a
handful but for me overall like in my
life you know I still like practicing
just came back from a boo gang rehearsal
and and that's been fun but yeah for me
that's kind of what I've been doing and
now I'm just trying to stay our time
thirty-six years old so I'm just trying
to stay committed and engaged to
something right like I it's lucky that
are working in school so I get to see a
lot of children that basically you know
that vibe of a kid picking up anything
and putting it down ten minutes later is
something that I'd like to continue to
have and I think a lot of people kind of
knock that but I think being a learner
that's kind of what that means you know
you're like I'm gonna try this thing
maybe I get into it put the yo-yo
sidewalk away I'm gonna try this thing
and I think that that's something at
least for me right now I'm trying to
like foster that
with the activities in my life is try to
you know not learn from my age where I'm
not just going full-bore next to me
until I burn myself and everyone do it
again
and also like barely do it so I've kind
of been finding this thing where I have
a wide variety of activities that I
enjoy and then I'll do some modular
origami or I'm like knitting again or
I'm like you know into this like plant
thing or I'm into you know whatever so
I'm just trying to like pace out they
enjoy them and enjoyable things my life
so yeah
so are you coming back to the states are
you gonna bring are you gonna come bring
like come to some of the u.s. fest and
maybe keep the workshop on what you've
done or do you have any ideas or maybe
go to the big burn and set up a sandwich
board or uh yeah kinda I don't want to
stay like I'm ready to leave but I also
need a reason to leave like I don't want
to just move randomly so I guess I'm
hoping to try to use those stuff with
the aged care to like try to pitch that
to other places so it's a very
transitioning time is very up in the air
we're kind of trying to see there's a
community here but like just to travel
from New Zealand is insane
like it's so expensive and takes so long
so like I just need to be closer bling
bling bling bling brother's doing group
out of art I think you're out of Oakland
there
like they do basketball juggling Mary
Michael they've come to the States
actually they came to IJA the
International Association event a couple
times but okay well I think it's time
for you to grab your cat and then we can
say goodbye and I have my boss this is
something I've been doing at the end of
these recently it's animal harassment
basically he's asleep is he okay is he a
boy yeah wake up cat oh my goodness look
at that oh my god we might just leave
him he's very peaceful what's his name
spider why is it 1314 years and when I
got him I lived in a basement and
there's a lot of spiders I didn't think
I was keeping him and he kept catching
and eating all the spiders now so
thankful so psycho you're a little like
spider catcher
what's name of your business again um
can we find it online
can anybody yeah patreon and I'm not
ready to just close that is recent yeah
so so wait no what has been released
about before we go what has been
released from your studies like I've
seen some articles
everything's out and where do we all
find that is that spin poit are calm as
well okay well with that I hope you come
to the States
I could easily as a I guess I can just
commit you come to any
say I event for free you should come
you've done nice things and you know not
gonna say anything particular but I knew
you got that grant and also we can talk
offline about that but but but yeah I
think that uh
I just really appreciate talking to you
and it's very rare that you have
somebody like yourself especially a
woman - I think that's like kind of like
a sign of just like a better like you're
the only person I know that's taken at
least POY the Accademia I have some
friends working on occupational therapy
with props but I really think that
that's an amazing endeavor and I thank
you for taking time out of your busy
schedule you know and and I know that
and also working out the time with me
because I know it's challenging to plan
anything right any last words where we
go but stay on okay uh no thanks yeah
it's only a buck a month I know I'm not
really pushing it very hard
[Music]